in every Harvard dorm there is a little
piece of history
a small red landline phone most of us
probably disconnected it on our first
day and stashed it in the back of a
closet or under a futon but imagine for
a moment we left that red phone
connected and imagine that it rang
we'd have no idea who was calling or
what they needed or even if the call was
meant for us the only way to find out
would be to pick up now we all have cell
phones to make us more connected but we
are all so busy that usually when we get
a call we rush to silence it we wonder
why didn't they just text me I received
a call about a year ago from a 16 year
old friend of mine named Avery Avery had
leukemia and I had had lymphoma several
years earlier
so naturally we talked about sports on
this particular phone call he told me
about his make-a-wish trip to the Super
Bowl with Jamie Foxx in Leonardo
DiCaprio Leo was the man he told me he
was rocking this giant beard and I met
Kate Upton and I was making her laugh
and she even gave me a kiss I teased
Avery that maybe there was still a
chance he would get Kate Upton's number
but in the meantime I was glad to hear
he was doing so well
tragically about a week later
Avery passed away it wasn't fair what
happens to Avery but I am always so
grateful that he and I shared that phone
call the warmth and the joy in his voice
always give me strength a lot of things
aren't fair at the beginning of the year
Dean karana asked us do we want to
prepare students for the world as it is
or the world as we want it to be it is
easy to disengage in the world as it is
when we hear of the suffering of people
from Iraq
to Newtown when we know the globe is
warming and the middle class is
shrinking it is easy to think that no
one can solve these big problems and to
conclude that no one should try but it
is also easy to disconnect in smaller
moments it's easy to answer
how are you with busy to end a
conversation rather than feel vulnerable
by opening up it's easy to sweetly lie
to those people in Harvard Square
holding clipboards I'll be back soon and
then avoid them for the rest of the day
it is easy to be unavailable because
each of us is working on something
important engaging requires us to choose
empathy to set aside time for what is
important to others but at Harvard in
ways big and small we engaged
we chose optimism over cynicism when we
plan an educational trip to Israel and
Palestine or we gave a voice to refugees
the world had left in the dust of
Western Tanzania we watched as fifth
graders beamed at their state senator
when she told them that they were all
actually her boss it reminded us that
our democratic political system so often
a punch line can still inspire we chose
to appreciate each other's gifts rather
than view them as threats to our own we
brought a latte to a friend up all night
in a lab across campus we cheered
together on Spring Break trips all over
the world when Steve's take the shot to
beat Yale as time expired
we chose empathy when we respectfully
disagree in class and said I just like
to push back on that in these moments we
glimpsed a world as we want it to be now
as we are about to leave this place
we're excited even Restless but we worry
who we like our new job will we get into
the right grad school will our parents
keep paying our cell phone bill most of
all I think we worry about losing our
ability to choose next year it will be
easy to stress about big meetings and
important presentations because our
bosses will tell us that they matter it
will be easy to spend even more time
being busy because that's how we're told
to get ahead it will be easy to
disengage and forget those special
moments that we shared here but in this
reality then before we worry about
changing the world let's remember and
let's choose not to let the world change
us let's invite someone who looks lost
to sit with us at lunch like we might
have in Annenberg let's give our
neighbor directions like we would to
tourists looking for the John Harvard
statue let's keep making time for our
friends even when we have a million
things we should be busy doing instead
like we did when we went out for drinks
after our roommates turned in their
theses and like we did for more drinks
when our roommates got their thesis
grades back Harvard Graduate Robert
Kennedy told South Africa under
apartheid each time we act to improve
the lot of others we send forth a tiny
ripple of hope crossing each other from
a million different centers those
ripples build a current which can sweep
down the mightiest walls of oppression I
see in front of me
thousands of
Ripple's toward a world as we want it to
be I see in our collective imaginations
and our combined actions the beginning
of a mighty current Robert Kennedy's
brother
President Kennedy installed in the Oval
Office a direct hotline to the head of
the Soviet Union
popularly depicted as a small red
landline phone they used it in times of
crisis to build a momentary connection
to day it would be easy to pretend there
is nothing we can do to disconnect to
stash other people's problems in the
back of a closet or under a futon but
instead let's connect our red phones and
make ourselves available for those small
serendipitous moments when someone needs
us let's engage even when it makes us
feel vulnerable because how we treat
each other
bit by bit will affect how leaders treat
leaders and how nations treat nations as
we celebrate our commencement let's
always remember that our diploma is not
a piece of paper rather it is a call a
call to see the world as it is and still
choose to imagine a world as we want it
to be right now the phone is ringing off
the hook
answering that call requires us to make
time but when we answer I believe we
will always be so grateful
that we did
you